good morning Millennials welcome back to
the chos
and
happy Stay With Me
Now Friday Friday got to get down on
Friday everybody is looking forward to
the weekend weekend Friday Friday
getting down on
Friday I like the version better where
we say Friday Friday Jackson Claw on
Friday literally when have we ever said
that it's in my head so we've said it
okay and we shall say it again I think
we should continue to change the lyrics
until they're our own yeah I love that
for us me too I hope that somewhere
somehow Rebecca Black knows that on one
of the high the top podcasts like I'm
not just saying this we are big podcast
biggest podcast on the planet on a very
large podcast we sing her song every
week honestly when it comes to that
particular song I don't feel like that
statistic would impress her because that
song is embedded in the fibers of our
culture no Claudia like no one is doing
more for that song than us actually
Rebecca Black is like she's releasing
remixes no one who's not financially
motivated or inced are financially
motivated no one who doesn't have a
financial stake in the song is doing
more for that song than us
s s you guys now that I hear it my life
is ruined um my life is not ruined
because toast merch dropped today and
honestly what's the opposite of ruined
made my life is made that's so true
toast merch dropped today at shop toast
merch.com and I am wearing my sweatpants
again today because they're that
comfortable and as I was walking up to
the studio I'm like these are the most
amazing sweatpants I've ever worn uh
drawring we love her we know her we are
her we see her I wore them on this
4-Hour flight yesterday why is it
literally so long to get to Texas I I
don't feel like it should be that long
to get from New York to Texas it's it's
it shouldn't be 4 hours it should be
three and a half like it is three and a
half it should be less I agree with you
but it's not four okay it was three and
a half but like you know with the with
the taxi and such for to the
pull it was four and I feel like that's
beyond unnecessary when it takes like a
little under six to get to La like it
just made no sense yeah but all that to
say I was extremely comfortable on my
flight in my new toast merch I wear size
medium Jackie wear size large like the
merch is flying off the shelves BL the
by the way for years it was Jackie's
wearing a medium cla's wearing an extra
large so please spare me okay and I just
want to say like I could have taken a
size down sure sure
wow sure I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding wow TTY and soon soon it's not
even going to fit me anymore cuz once
I'm done breastfeeding it's over for you
[__] um are you I was just having
this conversation with some of my
friends who just had babies they're all
thinking about like OIC what what do you
think about OIC like would you such a
great question I've so yes I would do
OIC between babies if I felt like I
needed to but I would rather not so
right now my plan is to not but I mean
I'm like I have like you know 15 20
pounds on a good day that I want to lose
and that's not like I need to be on OIC
but like if I were in a place where I
felt like pregnant at the weight that I
was at wouldn't be healthy again like
then I would I think it would be
healthier to take OIC between babies
than to get pregnant being severely
overweight which I know that I'm not so
but when I'm done having kids it's over
for you [__] yeah and so all that to
say like I we could sit here and like
Wax poetic about like why you should get
the merch but I do feel it's like
insulting to the intelligence of our
listeners especially when the merch is
quite literally flying off the shelves
like I don't even think we need to
promote it like let's just move on it's
so hot right now like quite literally
but what I will say is that it is like
an open order right now so you can place
your order right now we're going to
leave it open like that for a few days
before we place the order there will
still be merch available after that but
right now you can get your size
guaranteed but place your order now
place it now is what I'll say place it
now yeah Now's the Time to be placing it
but like Claudia said we don't even need
to be promoting it yeah like honestly I
feel like it does a it's like a
detriment to our image to continue to
talk about it
honestly in what way like I don't know
about a detriment law like I feel like
we would be seriously like speaking down
to our listeners to try and convince
them to buy this merch like they're
intelligent women their mothers their
business owners feel like I'm trying to
convince I just feel like I'm speaking
my truth today and what's on my mind and
what's on my mind is that my sweatpants
are really comfortable therefore I had
to wear them two days in a row so funny
when you said you're speaking like
what's on your mind you know it's like a
phrase I've been using a lot recently
that I feel I'm kind of appropriating it
from like Southern Culture you know when
someone's like you know you you've been
on my heart a lot recently I've been
saying that cuz like someone was on my
heart the other day you know it's a nice
saying it really is yeah there's some
nice Southern sayings like I've noticed
that they say like if you're going to go
like like see someone or hang with them
like you're going to go visit that
like yeah we use the word visit too in
the no but we don't use it like they use
it pay a visit what pay a visit yeah
like or I'm going to go visit with you
like if I was going over to your house
I'd be like I'm going to go visit with
Claudia oh yeah we don't say that we
don't say that and it's a nice way to
say it instead of being like I'm going
to go be a slob on tury's couch right
I'm going to go pay a visit to tur's
couch yeah I'm going to go pay a visit
I'm actually in the South I'm in Texas
right now so I'm going to keep my ears
and eyes out for new phrases to bring
home to the toast that we can
appropriate um going to the rodeo this
weekend super excited so just don't mind
me you a little a little Bic Coastal
podcasting this is kind of you love
saying you're by Coastal when you are
not in fact by Coastal so just so
everyone like I can clear up any
confusion when I say by Coastal I mean
I'm I'm not in New York you're out of
state and I'm not doing a video podcast
today's episode is Audio Only I have my
travel microphone with me when I have my
travel microphone I am by Coastal
podcasting okay okay works for me also
when I'm in Florida and you you're in
New York you also like to say we're by
Coastal no I say we're transatlantic
then oh the other day you said by
Coastal but I don't correct you because
I know what you mean so it's like what's
the point what's the point thank you so
much and I know I I don't think I'm
using it correctly like I know I'm not
and every it's like me and Elk but I'm
just letting the other people know that
we know lest we not forget like I know
that's not the right way of using it I'm
going to continue to use it incorrectly
grab a spoon and eat my
ass even though that one if you listen
to patreon you know I'm not even
apologizing for niku so I just wanted to
point out that this is the third Friday
in a row we're doing an audio only
Extravaganza and you know what it's
giving summer Fridays it's giving you
know year of yes like it's January so
I'm like doing all these things taking
all these trips saying yes to life and
that's why for the last three Fridays in
a row your well one of them I was sick
but your girl has been transatlantically
podcasting yeah what do you think about
transatlantically podcasting for a title
today if nothing better comes up sure
okay jot it down in your memory the
titles just this week have been off the
rails let's talk about this week in
toast history and let's talk about
everyone's noticing we're kind of the
name on everyone's lips everybody's
talking about how the toast this week in
particular released four going on five
episodes that just hit different
everyone is talking about how different
the episodes are how funny we are and
they want to know like what happened
that's why somebody thought I was on
drugs like that's how different they are
and I want to give the people an answer
and I genuinely don't have one for my
part I can cite two things but I I don't
know about you but for me two things
were different for me this week from
most recent weeks one I had went to
Disney and that changes a person it does
two Charlie is sleeping longer stretches
in the night and I feel like a human
being again oh by the way that's it but
it takes two to toast tur no no that's
it cuz like you have been particular
funny like and when you're you were more
funny this week than you usually are and
like when you're funny like it makes me
like crazy you know oh interesting well
then I really think it has to do with
the fact that I'm once again getting
sleep like the 4mth Sleep progression
for us was so real not like he was
sleeping through the night before 4
months but like we were getting chunks
before and then it all just fell apart
and for the last few weeks I was up
every 2 to three hours and it was and
then also getting him back it was just
like really hard but last night for
example he went down around 7:30 he
didn't eat until 5: again like that's
King [__] yeah that's King [__] and then
he slept down like went back to sleep
till 8 think about Charlie is he kind of
likes to sleep in and this morning he
only woke up because Bruno woke him up
[__] Bruno no but Bruno Just deci it
was like 8:15 Bruno's like everyone up
and Adam I want to start my day give me
my breakfast I want my dinner now yeah
and he was two breakfast Tigs this
morning or just one just one maybe even
I don't know I didn't see it happen if I
had to pinpoint perhaps what caused a
shift in my podcast Persona this week
was that I was sick during the weekend
and as the week progressed I kept
feeling better and better and I was
feeling like my myself again perhaps
that was it I feel like also because you
were sick all weekend you had all this
pent up energy cuz you weren't out and
about like giving all of yourself to the
rest of the world so you were able to
give all of yourself to us so what
you're saying is like for my job I
should start staying in on the
weekends yeah you need to rest and
recover you're an athlete this is a
sports podcast this is a sports podcast
and speaking of like this is our last
episode before we know who's going to
the Super Bowl so let's like give our
final predictions we have been saying
for a while or at least I have I think
that it's going to be Niners and Ravens
which means that it's going to be the
Lions and the other Chiefs Chiefs oh
that's a good Super Bowl oh I don't
agree with that I think like there's
really no chance that you know I don't
want to jinx anything but I'm
so no last year we like literally did
this sort of episode we predicted who
was going to the Super Bowl and it was
the exact opposite of who went to the
Super Bowl which so I think it's going
to be Detroit and the Chiefs then in
that case okay no but I feel like if
you're saying it's Niners Ravens which
would mean that it's going to be Kansas
City Detroit I think that means it's
going to be Detroit's
49ers half of each Jackie it can't be
Detroit 49ers okay Detroit and the
others you mean Chiefs and the
ners I think it's going to be Detroit
Ravens and I just want to say like I
have the utmost respect for both teams
and may the best team win it really
might be one of those too but like a
more lackluster Super Bowl combo you
couldn't find based on on the options no
based on like the year that we've had in
terms of like the NFL's place in culture
if we do end up with the Ravens and the
debt which both teams are so deserving
this is not a slight Detroit is one of
Lifetime once in a lifetime quarterback
the debt the first in 66 years you can't
like sh up the history blah blah blah
but given what you know sort of
Renaissance the NFL has had in culture
this year having to do with celebrities
like Taylor Swift like the use checks
like Olivia kulo like there's a lot
going on and if we end up with like two
kind of like celebrity lists teams like
it will be lame I'm sorry it will I
really have been thinking a lot about
what you said which is that it is in the
NFL's best interest to get the Chiefs to
the Super Bowl yeah it is and now that
you've said that I can't unhear it and I
feel like they'll be going to the Super
Bowl and did you say on this show or was
it Zach talking to me it's also crazy
how much like Zach and I talk about
sports now and it's really like it's
good for our relationship to have like a
more common interest but so it was
either you or him who said that the ref
that they chose okay the ref that they
chose for the Kansas City game is
usually favorable to the away team and
Kansas City is the away team like I feel
like the NFL wants tayor swifted the
Super Bowl right and not that
necessarily the NFL is scripted but they
might you know do some things because it
is in their best interest to move the
needle a little bit they might pull some
levers so we'll really just have to wait
and see I know I think I've said this
now three times but I did change my
flight to an earlier flight like to get
home to watch the game that is time
number three this is gonna be such a
fabulous weekend going to the rodeo
doing all the southern Tings and then on
Sunday like being a real like you know
not like other girls girl speaking of
Southern Tings yesterday you were
telling me about Pooky and jet and when
we hung up I went down a rabbit hole I
didn't even have to go that far down the
rabbit hole to become obsessed I just
need to state that Pooky is a toaster
because of course she is she is I am so
obsessed like it literally took two
videos for me to get it like yep yep yep
it's so funny and so cute and just so
pure and I think that's why people
really are gravitating towards them
because we don't get just like pure true
love like this it's a fantasy she like
one in one Buren and she got two yeah
it's a fantasy and also by the way you
just reminded me why I've been saying
the phrase you've been on my heart
recently Pooky and Jet were on my heart
recently because I get like really
panicked when
people like especially on Tik Tok people
discover something become obsessed with
them because the the natural next step
is that they're people on the internet
are going to try and destroy this thing
that they once loved and Pooky and Jet
are like having this moment where
they're so sweet and so innocent and
they're just this lovely married couple
they live in Atlanta they don't bother
anyone and everyone's obsessed with them
and the natural like life cycle of the
internet is the next thing they're going
to do is destroy these two and I was
thinking about them I was like thinking
of sending them a message almost just
being like you know it's amazing right
now and it might not always be amazing
but like just be yourselves and don't
like they were on my heart they were on
my heart they were on on your heart well
my DMs with Pokey are open now oh
probably yours too because she just she
saw that she heard us listening she
heard us talking about her on the toast
yesterday I feel like I was just having
this conversation um with someone about
like you know Tik Tok has really changed
like what it means to be an influencer
and there's so many I feel like the
girlies we know like from Instagram have
been doing this for so long and they
have like really good steady jobs with
that you know they're not like the
biggest influencers on the planet but
they're moms and they pay their bills
and make a really good living being like
steady influencers who have grown slowly
over like the course of 5 or 10 years on
Instagram whereas now it's like this new
economy on Tik Tok where people in a
matter of minutes like their lives are
changed but it really remains to be seen
if there's any longevity with that and
there are certain people who I think
like have cemented themselves I keep
setting these examples of like these
overnight successes on Tik Tok like
Emily Maro and it's like you get you
have these five minutes and what you do
with those five minutes when you're at
the top will you know set the course for
your career and how you handle those
opportunities and I feel like for Alex
Earl it was a perfect example of
somebody who did it perfectly like she
took every opportunity and I do really
feel like she will be an influential
person for many many years to come
agreed then I think about Emily Maro who
I feel just based on Vibes like didn't
want that she doesn't want to be the
biggest hottest thing like I'm sure
she's really happy being able to be a
content creator full-time but she was
getting married she's pregnant like I
feel like she didn't want that and so
she intentionally didn't take those
opportunities I am sure when her salmon
bow took over the world every
opportunity was not and it appears as
though she didn't take any
right yeah I don't know her like you
guys do because I'm not on Tik Tok she's
someone this actually is a perfect
example like she didn't transcend right
and I I feel like it was intentional
like she didn't come out with a line of
anything she really didn't do many brand
Partnerships like she just like quietly
quit her job she had like a big fancy
job I think at meta or something she was
like working in Tech cuz she lives in
San Fran and now she content creates
full-time I'm sure she makes an amazing
living and like it's enough for her you
know di so I find it so interesting like
what these hot commodity Tik Tok people
are doing with their 5 minutes and how
they're setting themselves up and I feel
like if you fumble the ball in those 5
minutes
like you'll still be you know relevant
for a little bit but not in like in the
way that Alex Earl is like I think she's
really set herself up really
nicely yeah but it's also like you could
plan to do things right but people like
you might just not have that factor of
like people are going to care about you
for longer than those five minutes yeah
cuz maybe like maybe you went it depends
did you go viral for something that was
kind of like a fluke thing how do
recreate that versus like if you go
viral for who you are
yep it's just an interesting thing to be
looking out for you know yeah no it's um
and it's like which would you prefer
which would you prefer like the way you
know me I'm I'm slow and steady ttis in
the hair yeah and that's really how we
did it
yeah TRS y so we've got stories today
we've also got Queenie and weenie of the
week and I just want to say all week
I've been like keeping a list on my
phone of like things that remind me like
a oh write down that person could be
weenie of the week and I don't know what
it says about me that I have a the
longest list of weenies and not one
Queenie not one that's really funny I
feel like I have so many queenies this
week you know what like maybe you should
do the Queenie and I'll do the weenie
because oh I like that I have a hard
time with weenie oh my God weenie is so
I'm such a Negative like miserable
person it's so easy for me that is so
funny okay well let's get into the
stories because you have a bowl to ride
yes I have a busy day you know this
whole weekend we're doing things I've
never done Stockyards you know what that
is yeah I watch real house of Dallas so
I right right right so I'm Stockyard and
I got to get some boots I want to get
like a hat like I have a lot to
do you are have a lot to do so without
further Ado here are the fast five
stories that you need to know and the
fast five stories that you need to know
are brought to you by Honey Love ladies
we have a New Year's resolution for you
that's actually easy to keep this is the
year to finally stop wearing
uncomfortable bras support for today's
episode comes from Honey Love they have
revolutionalized the bra game for you to
no longer deal with uncomfortable
underwire without sacrificing support
you will immediately feel and see the
difference their brows are super
comfortable and you won't want to take
them off for limited time you can get
honey love on sale get 20% off your
entire order with the exclusive link
honey love.com toast support for the
show today check them out at Honey
love.com
toast so we all have go-to bras that we
pick over everything else in their
closet and the Honey Love crossover bra
is so comfortable it will be sure to be
your new go-to this bra gives all the
support of traditional bras but it
doesn't use any underwire plus the mesh
detailing adds a little touch of
sexiness so this is the traditional bras
without using any underwire it's the one
time it is the one bra you will actually
enjoy wearing and you won't want to take
off I happen to love just all the
products from honey love I trust them
implicitly as a brand I started with a
lot of their undergarments you know like
you know power shorts they have leggings
their leggings 2.0 is another product
that's Making Waves for them they hold
you in without feeling too tight and
they are compressive Cooling and
comfortable so whether your New Year's
resolution is to get up and get active
spend more time at home lounging these
leggings are the goto so treat yourself
to the best bras in shapewear on the
market and save 20% off at Honey
love.com toast use the link for 20% off
that's honey love.com toast after you
purchase they'll ask where you heard
about them so please support the toast
and tell them we sent you start the new
year off with confidence thanks to Honey
Love today's episode is also brought to
you by hatch you know sleep is
everything to me in a deep and sort of
biblical sense and since I've started
using my hatch I have really prioritized
resting again and I've noticed a huge
change in my energy levels during the
day so added to the list of things
Jackie told me to get and I didn't
listen to she's like yeah it's like this
thing where like light wakes you up I'm
like yeah sure my phone is fine my phone
was not fine the hatch is gamechanging
Ben was like so anti once I brought it
into the room Ben was like no no I need
my sound machine I'm like no you don't
hatch has everything now every night
before bed he's like hey uh can you uh
put on the hatch so the hatch restore is
a device that teaches your body when
it's time to sleep or wake up with
nighttime and morning routines that you
can prioritize rest with hatch plus you
can access exclusive content like Pillow
Talk their new audio series designed to
entertain you to Sleep Pillow Talk helps
you wind down with the types of TV shows
that you normally love from True Crime
to sports but without the screens and
the blue light that will hurt healthy
rest in the morning hatch is going to
wake you up gently with a sunrise alarm
so you can set it so the light comes on
first and then personalize your alarm
sound to come in 15 to 30 minutes later
it's such a civilized way of waking up
like waking up through light I that's
how the cavemen did it and we've just
sort of regressed as a society great
sleep can be learned when hatch 83% of
customers report improv sleep I said on
the toast this week that I've been
waking up on my own so much earlier now
and I really really believe that it's
because of the hatch they have a 60
night money back guarantee so you can
try it yourself risk-free right now
hatch is offering our listeners $20 off
their purchase of a hatch restore and
free shipping at hatch. toast visit
hatch. toast to get $20 off in free
shipping hatch.
toast thank you la well um our first
story is a big story of this Friday
Sophia Richie gra is pregnant and it's a
Vogue exclusive and it's a girl so
Sophia she's doing all of it at the same
time announcing her pregnancy fire
photos gender reveal interview about
pregnancy and it's really a beautiful
thing so she is six months along her and
Elliot got married in April so N9 months
ago so I think everybody's just like did
when did they get pregnant um in the
interview she talks about how after
their wedding they were like casually
trying to not try you know so she had
taken like pregnancy tests but they
weren't like super trying or trying not
to get pregnant um so she was very
excited when they were pregnant and
she's just been keeping it under wraps
learning all
about all of the female form baby making
and she seems over the Moon I mean this
is so iconic on so many levels like
first of all a pregnancy announcement in
Vogue like when you're 25 is just like
so iconic I can't even her husband was
in some photos the solo ones of her like
body she's just so beautiful and she's
carrying so beautifully and this is just
gorgeous also like I feel like we don't
have a lot of like Role Models like
Sophia Richie for young women she's so
traditional in in an odd sense she's
like a very modern woman she's like this
businesswoman you know Mogul yada yada
but she's so traditional you know she
got married kind of young pregnant
quickly after and I just feel like she's
so different from the like other people
who like girls look up to and it's nice
to diversify Your Role Models I totally
agree I think she's a great role model I
love this trend I feel like it was
happening for a while it's not a trend
it's actually the opposite of what a
trend is it's Trad it's not a trend it's
a Trad it's not a trend it's a Trad but
for a while like there were a couple
celebrities getting married young and I
we thought that was like just a nice
different different path for people to
look up to and it's like cool to see the
coolest people doing it I feel like
she's doing that now and just setting a
really good example in in a different
way for girls if who want to follow a
path like this yeah and like I feel like
we said that about her wedding about how
so much of like her aesthetic was so
modest almost in a sense and traditional
in its you know styling and it wasn't
overly sexual or anything and she was
just very like classy in the way that
she dressed and she really influenced a
generation of young girls to dress like
that which is so nice and I just feel
like she's really this like
gorgeous role model for real yeah we
that about her sty like I look at Margo
and I'm like Margo's wearing trousers
all the time now and cardigans thank you
Sophia Richie gra yeah and I just
thought the way that whoever is sort of
um managing her at this time like making
these decisions whether it's her or it's
a team is really doing a great job she
hasn't hit that level of like
overexposure yet where I feel like at
her wedding it almost got to a place
where I was like okay enough but then
she like went a little silent started
just doing her little Jo Malone brand
deals and she's been very smart about it
and this is obviously like a huge moment
and they made a big moment out of it and
I think her waiting till she was six
months pregnant was obviously a choice
and doing it in Vogue is a choice and I
think it's really just gorgeous tens
tens tens across the board here yeah and
now that she's revealed her pregnancy
I'm excited to see her pregnancy style
she said that like she's kind of just
been concealing the pregnancy with coats
and whatnot but now that she is out and
about like she'll be showing it off and
that I'm excited to see because I feel
like she will bring new fresh pregnancy
style I do think it's really interesting
when people celebrities influencers
choose to share their pregnancy and like
when they choose to do it really late or
really early um because I just was
looking at this picture Nick vile posted
like really cute picture of him and
Natalie and her belly was like the
centerpiece of the photo and somebody's
like I feel like Natalie's been pregnant
for a hundred years like imagine how
Natalie
feels no and people say that and it's so
annoying when people say that like shut
up seriously imagine how the woman feels
yeah um so I do think it's interesting
when people choose to wait I feel like
they choose to wait so that they don't
have that effect on people I don't think
that you're caring about what other
people are going to think I think it's
more so it depends Superstition you are
Superstition of course you want to reach
a certain Milestone but then especially
in your first pregnancy like if you can
hide it cuz you show Less in your first
pregnancy than you do in subsequent
pregnancies in your second like you get
uh bumper
faster yeah and more and more but I
think in your first you realize like hey
I can kind of get away with this and
it's like nice to have this like secret
and this private thing for yourself
especially when you're a public person
and it's like nice to keep it to
yourself as long as you can I feel like
that's kind of where they were at also
she said in the interview like she
didn't realize how many different
Milestones you have to reach and how
many tests and how everything is really
so precarious so I think you do become
really protective and you just want to
like keep this thing hold it close it's
that maternal Instinct until you're
literally busting at the seams and
you're like okay I'm pregnant here you
go yeah yeah yeah yeah um I love this
like I love her yeah and she has been
really quiet recently and I feel like
because she's been in the throw of
pregnancy no like I really can't with
these [__] idiotic [__] [__]
[__] oh her and her genocide
supporting husband giving birth to a
genocide supporter seriously you are one
of the dumbest ugliest people I've ever
met in my life start learning the
English language cuz you obviously don't
know what words mean Eng start learning
English start learning history start
learning the coms were so anti-semitic I
was like screenshotting stuff to like
make a post about it but I'm like okay
not I'm not going to make like her
moment yeah don't make it about that but
the comments were so disappointing I
can't these are the worst people these
are the worst of the human elk and human
nature like no Jackie they're the worst
of the human
ilk yeah I'm GNA use it right this time
okay you can use it right this time
because if someone's listening they're
like you're calling them dumb no like it
was so disappointing and I wasn't even
expecting it like I forget like she
converted to Judaism her husband is
Jewish and they're like supporters of
Israel I didn't even think I didn't even
think of it I just wanted to see what
people were saying like it was so
disappointing no they ruined everything
like literally they're at Sundance Film
Festival they're in the middle of the
highway did you see that video they've
been protesting like Manhattan Bridge
every day or whatever and there was a
man who like needed to pick up his
daughter yes and he's like they he can't
get through like they ruin everything y
so it's no surprise they would try and
ruin a beautiful moment such as this but
she pess bearded she'll be
fine are you ready for our next story I
am some I guess big news Morgan Wallen
is fighting back against an early EP
reissue of his music so Morgan Wallen
put out a statement on his Instagram
last night because an album is coming
out
that is by Morgan Wallen but he is
making it clear to fans that he is not a
part of this album he recorded it way
early on in his career when he was under
like weird ass management and he signed
a bad deal and like these people have
the rights to his old music and they're
putting out the songs again and there's
it's sung by Morgan Wallen so it's going
to be like a part of his catalog but he
wants to make clear to fans that this is
not like in uh sanctioned by him and
this is not his new music there's one
song one song on the album called spin
you around became like a fan favorite
from this early EP so he surprised fans
with a re-recording of it so he's like
trying to thwart the interest in that
new old album yeah he basically was like
this weird album's coming out that I
literally made when I was 12 with these
freaks I I did not sanction it I do not
allow it so I just want you to know it's
coming out please don't support it but
there is a song on there that I know
like the fandom loves so instead don't
listen to that one here's my version
it's giving Taylor's version um and it's
just like one of those things I feel
like we all know the music industry is
so crazy like you know young Talent like
at this point it's almost like a talking
point we know they take advantage of
young talent but to know that like a
whole ass album can be released of your
voice without your approval years later
is like lowkey so crazy yeah seriously
crazy he said that at the time they made
13 songs he said some were okay most
were terrible as I was just learning how
to write in general and figuring it all
out I was not the only collaborator so
many of these songs were not my idea nor
met my standards we deemed five worthy
enough to make the alone EP which
includes the fan favorites spin you
around and now they are releasing those
songs that were like can back then but
they're just trying to capitalize on the
Wallen of course like you have this
batch of unreleased Morgan Wallen songs
people are dying for new Morgan Wallen
music like if you're a greedy person
you're just going to release it without
any care in the world the other part of
this excuse me statement that I thought
was really interesting is that he also
donated $100,000 to this like legal fund
that helps what's it called volunteer
lawyer and Professionals for the arts
program which I think just like offers
free legal services to people like you
Morgan Wallen when he was 15 who might
have found themselves in a situation
like this and I think that's actually uh
the coolest part of this statement
that's like really um that's awesome
yeah that
is doing something moving the needle
yeah and hopefully helping the next
person so that they're not in a position
like this as a Morgan Wallen fan I will
not be listening to those songs mostly
cuz I still have albums from his songs
from his new albums that I haven't
listened to cuz they're so damn long and
I feel like his fans and his fans like
really love him ride for him I feel like
they will honor this request and not
listen yeah of course but he had to let
us know like if if we all just saw this
thing coming out of course I would be
like uh okay sure I'll listen I think
he's handled this as best as possible
between the statement the re-recording
and the
donation I think there's nothing no no
no no do you think he contacted Taylor
Swift no I don't think Taylor Swift
would pick up his take up his phone call
me neither oh my god did you see the
drama with Taylor Swift and the AI
photos yes so I didn't want to like give
air to it clicks yeah yeah yeah but I I
do believe it's been like widely taken
down um so like an AI company generated
like really explicit pornographic
basically photos of Taylor Swift they
look very real I haven't seen them they
apparently look very real I think
they're like football themed um I saw
what I think are two of them I wouldn't
say they look very real they look like
AI oh okay yeah I wasn't confused um and
they went mega mega viral
and there were a couple articles like
that said they were from you know
Taylor's camp that she was like really
really mad about it um and it is like
this legal gray area currently with AI
and a lot of people think that like
because it happened to Taylor she might
pursue it legally and create some sort
of legal precedent around like making
exploitive and pornographic images of
mostly
women making it illegal yeah that's good
and by the way I just want to say the
two that I saw like were not
pornographic they were just
um they were just not real photos so
maybe I didn't see but like to me you
could it I think most people would be
able to tell that they're AI because
they have that sort of like AI look to
them but but if there are like
pornographic explicit photos it's like
just it doesn't have to look like it's
it's it's gross it's gross and it's
inappropriate and I agree there's
definitely legal gray area I saw that
there was this mom who her daughter had
been like yes someone made like AI like
deep fake porn of her that like she was
14 yeah like circulated and so she's
been really like championing so I do
think that there is law that needs to be
written for this and maybe Taylor Swift
is the right person to like spearhead I
think a lot of people are hoping that
she will pursue legal action like
usually internet drama is not something
she puts herself into but like if there
is anyone who can create like literally
take it to the Supreme Court and create
some sort of like legal precedent it
would be Taylor Smith because she has
the means to like fund that sort of
legal fight um but people are just so
[__] disgusting like it's insane to
me like it's really gross yeah like who
thinks to come up like what if I just
asked AI to create like Taylor Swift
poror go get a girlfriend like don't
just St being a freak I ask AI to help
me write an Instagram caption
okay I asked AI to like recommend a book
to me and they couldn't even do it okay
I asked AI to recommend some books to me
and there was one that I could tell was
like an amazing choice I Dana read it
she said it was like I I told Dana about
it I was like have you read this she was
like no she read it she said it was
amazing I wish I chose it for the
redheads next redhead's pick I'm asking
AI should have been reading where the
forest meets the
stars that was the book like that's what
we should be using AI for like somebody
used AI to generate a photo of Theo in
heaven for me and that meant a great
deal to me thank you you so how do you
do that like okay I don't know because I
then went on chat gbt and I was like can
you show me a picture of Theo or
whatever and they were like sorry we
don't generate photos so it's like a
different service I don't know a
different service yeah it's not chat
it's not the ones we're used to like
chat gbt I use chat gbt yeah duh do you
know that Elon started open
AI with Sam Alman oh okay I was going to
say I thought Sam Alman did with Sam
Alman and then like Sam alman's it was
supposed it was a non for-profit when he
started with Sam M because Elon really
believes in like ethical Ai and that AI
should have limitations that it never
takes over humans whereas other AI um
Founders think that AI should be able to
get as intelligent as it can get so Elon
started open AI to um combat that and
then like Sam mman started like a
for-profit arm of it so I was getting
like I feel like with Sam Alman he got
like everyone he was like the people's
man but there's definitely something oh
you feel like there's a dark side of Sam
mman I feel like there's a dark side of
Sam mman I do she said it here first you
guys she said it here first yeah I don't
think him like him and Elon started
together and I don't even
think they talk anymore that's weird it
is weird so just thought you should know
thought you should know that all those
to don't stream
Morgan some more streaming news Okay
Britney Spears fans are streaming her
2011 song selfish instead of Justin
Timberlake's new single oh by the way
I'm so glad you brought up Justin
Timberlake's new single cuz I listen to
like a quick snippet of it because
somebody I saw like toaster saying like
wait it's actually good so I'm like okay
I can I'm like a wench but I you know
I'm a reasonable person I didn't think
it was good I listened to maybe three
seconds I don't know how it came across
my desk and I thought it was fine his
voice just annoys me like if someone
else was singing that song I think I
would like it but I don't like his voice
no and he did like he's doing the rounds
he did Zan low and he's like this is the
greatest piece of art I've ever put out
like I'm sure every artist says that but
like this is my best work yet and I just
don't think that's possible because like
say you want about him but like there
was a time period where he released like
really amazing music no I feel like he
still has good music in him but I just
don't like his voice at this point I
can't unar him yeah what's that song I
don't want to lose you now I'm looking
right at the like that is an amazing
song Can't Stop the feeling I was going
to say can't stop the feeling is his
like last great hit yeah that song like
took over the world people forget that
it's him but it's him yeah cuz it's also
the trolls movie which is so weird
classic the trolls movie is constantly
turning out bangers it's broken and it's
beautiful speaking of Kelly do you know
the song my favorite kind of high of
course from her new album yeah do you
know the David ghetto
remix it came up on my Spotify like
somebody had spot I knew that I needed
to hear this song
Jackie it is probably the only thing
that can get me to like get on the
treadmill like it's so I just listened
to it on repeat it's so good it's like a
[__] popping
song that is so great there's a great
David geta remix of something that you
need to listen to David geta is like
David geta you know I know I'm saying
nobody geta is like David and I geta it
like it's David geta do you ever listen
to heartbreak Anthem David geta
remix okay great J that's like that's my
song like that is my number that's my
numberx you know
my gires I miss them every day the world
is a darker place without Little Mix I
just want to say ever since they broke
up or went on Hiatus like things have
been going down shit's been
[__] everything look at look around at
the world and tell me it's not
correlated not correlated to little
mix's dissolution the environment no
you're so right war war when Little Mix
was turning out hits there was peace
peace something to think about yeah
anyways Britney fans are streaming
Britney songs instead of Justin
Timberlake's new music her song selfish
is already up to number four while his
is at number one right now okay like
we'll let him have his Moment Justin
Timberlake is just not really ever going
to be at the level that he was like he
needs to just kind of accept that he's
taken a
hit I think that anything is possible
and he could get back to being that
person that's what I think but not if he
just like keeps doing this it's like
he's banging his head again so while
like oh I'm going to put out new music
Timberlake forward ifite us a book or
give us like a be style documentary but
like there needs to be an understanding
because he has some things to answer for
I don't think that there aren't answers
and I think that maybe there are answers
that we just need to hear from him but
there are now too many questions no by
the way you're 100% right there is no
response for everything that's coming
come out in the last couple of years and
him just moving on like everything's
fine and dandy it's like it's giving
cringe I don't know what what the right
platform for his like a book would be
good a documentary would be good I don't
think enough people would read a book
yeah and I think I think
documentary or yeah or like a long form
podcast I'm sure he does that but I'm
sure it's like Dak Shepard asking him
like what his favorite fruit is yeah no
no we need like the real like he needs
to just kind of peel back the curtain
and if the answer is like yeah I did all
that [__] I was an [__] I was 22 I
was the most famous guy in the world
like I think there is a level of
understanding there like maybe there's
not a some big thing we don't know that
excuses all of his actions but maybe he
wants to sit down and be like no I was
like a big ass loser prick like okay
yeah and it's like then what changed
that you're not that person anymore
right maybe meeting your wife becoming a
father I think a lot of people could
relate to that Journey yeah maybe
there's also things maybe Justin's been
through stuff maybe he hasn't talk about
it all the time but like maybe there are
things that have upset him
maybe so I'm going to vote
documentary okay and if it had been in
like a documentary injunction with new
music yeah powerful
powerful I want to say something so
Random when we landed last night we
grabbed dinner and I had a glass grabbed
it that's a phrase I don't like yeah
because also it implies like I went to a
drive-thru like I had a full-blown meal
at a restaurant no but like sometimes
like when someone texts you like hey
want to grab dinner this week like I
don't want to grab it I would like to
sit civilized man no if someone texted
me that I would like it not like do you
want to have dinner to I like a would
you like to you're just too formal like
you're too formal for this generation I
guess but like really grabbing dinner
has always been a phrase that bothered
me and something I would never use okay
so Ben and I ate dinner no but maybe you
did grab it if it was after the airport
no no but it was like civilized like we
went down to the hotel so you didn't
grab it no we didn't grab it we like we
enjoyed it we enjoyed dinner and I had a
glass of
champagne and it was just like kind of
the craziest thing I've ever done were
you high as a kite it was so
lovely I just want to say like justice
for champagne that's all I'm saying I
understand what you mean I like a couple
SS of champagne there's like no lighter
feeling I had one I didn't don't even
think I finished a whole glass like just
almost one glass but the Comedown from
Champagne is not worth do you mean in
the morning I don't know when it
sometimes it hits an hour later it's
true sometimes it's the next morning
like it's horrible yeah it's like this
really sort of headache inducing
maniacal feeling like if if champagne is
light like the come down is heavy hard
hard H well our next story is related to
our previous story because Jessica Beal
is making headlines she says that she
loves eating in the shower oh I saw this
this morning on Instagram um she finds
it satisfying this is giving attention
seeking like I know celebrities like
sometimes like will slip or admit that
they do something weird and I feel like
they actually really do do that and it's
weird and they didn't think people would
make such a big deal out of it this is
giving like staged I'm sorry no one on
the face of the [__] planet eats in
the shower and I eat everywhere I feel
like it was one of those things where
she's like feels like she's coming clean
and we could all be like oh I do that
too like G George raising her hand and
Mean Girls like I've been bullied and
this is just like no we don't do that
nobody does that I I I want to say that
you don't even do that no Jackie she
doesn't do it like I know that this
whole story is fake and I'm mad that we
even chose it as a story because we fell
for her trap this is all a part of it's
not going for her trap this is a part of
her and Justin's like SCH like really
poorly strategized scheme to get people
to care about them again this is not me
falling from her trap this is me seeing
her trap picking it up off the floor and
saying Jessica be set a
trap this is me seeing Jessica's trap
picking up off the floor and saying this
is a
trap no it's a trap and me saving fellow
Mice from entering into the Trap do not
fall for this like we're moving on this
is not real nobody eats in the shower
not even let me tell you what she said I
want to I want to describe the trap to
you she took to Tik Tok to Rave about
eating in the shower claiming it's
deeply satisfying and saves her time she
said it's pretty simple guys you can do
this I find it deeply satisfying she has
a set of rules cring she has a set of
rules for shower eating which involves a
ledge to stick a coffee or a yogurt
container on Gross I'm sorry actually
that's gross yogurt in the shower but
also how do you do your yogurt with the
spoon because the spoon topples the
yogurt canister you really can't set it
down unless you're using a plastic spoon
she said but you know she doesn't use
plastic no definitely not she said I
like to take a bite or a sip and put it
on the ledge and then you do your thing
you wash your hair keep the soap out
that's a big deal the only tricky thing
is when you're chewing so the whole time
that you're eating you got to keep your
mouth closed because I still like to get
under the water while I'm chewing and
for whatever reason I want to open my
mouth at the same time and is disgusting
she's under the water while she's
chewing okay Jessica Simpson set Jessica
Simpson Jessica Beal set this trap for
us to like think of her as relatable and
oh adverse effect I think she's
disgusting and
unhygienic no I don't think
I I just no this doesn't work like If
This Were A Thing more people would do
it there's a reason why we don't Jessica
doesn't do heard of the only thing I've
heard of that I've never actually done
but it always sounds like a good idea is
like having bringing your coffee into
the shower because apparently like it
really awakens you if you like sip on it
between showers which that's fine that's
not what that's not a [__] yogurt no
I have like drawn myself a bath and
grabbed like a die Coke and a bowl of
pretzels like that's different no no no
Claudia that's so different that's luy
that's not even of this elk okay okay
she's a liar and a fraud and not
relatable and if she is doing this like
she needs to stop yeah it's true
honestly like she would be better off
coming clean as a as as a liar than
someone who actually does this and do
you think that this is put out at this
time to gender Goodwill to the beel
timberlakes they are like on a mission
to like come back not maybe at the level
that they were but they don't want to be
hated anymore and she's like not hated
she's worked
she's done some things during his Hiatus
but you know they're just not it right
now and they just kind of need to
understand that yeah like sometimes you
just have to just sit take a seat in
your mansion and you'll be fine yeah I
that's why I don't feel sorry you have
so many chairs to choose from I don't
feel sorry so many rooms to sulk in are
you ready for our fifth and final story
I am some drama I've been like kind of
following CU I think it's kind of crazy
okay Alexis bolina was joining rejoining
the real housing
in a friend Ro she was spotted filming
with Heather du and Emily Simpson but
what's CRA is is that she is now dating
John Jansen who is Shannon madore's ex
of many years they just broke up and now
he's dating Alexis Bolino I did know
that that's crazy Alexis bino is just
kind of this like gnat like she will
she's just like this
omnipresent like presence in the OC
Universe like you cannot get rid of me
[__] she's going to come back around
like just when you think she's gone boom
there she
is yeah this kind of makes me want to
get back into OC I think she should be a
cast member for this reason her and John
Janson seem very serious but also
Shannon and John Jansen seemed very
serious and they were for like many
years
yeah I just think it's so
crazy I think it's crazy too and like
what is there one single man in OC John
Jansen perhaps it's giving Tom dagostino
yes that's an amazing in comparison
except from what I saw of John Jansen I
didn't see a lot and I don't know
anything and I haven't watched in a few
years he seemed like a good guy yes I
watched a bunch of this Seasons where he
was on and they seemed like they were in
a fine relationship there were like
moments where they were like really
toxic but that was because they were
drinking and like I don't know if it's
necessarily emblematic of their relation
of him being toxic but then Shannon like
was in a toxic era after her and John
Jansen broke up that's when she got her
DWI like I don't know where the toxicity
was coming from her or him yeah that's a
good
point it is crazy that Alexis bolina is
dating him like the world is so small
yeah and so she has to get back on the
show she is back right now in a friend
role she was filming with Heather and
Emily and for the roke stands like next
season we'll probably be a good one
maybe I can get back on into it yeah and
those were the fastf five stories I feel
as though you needed to know them I
definitely feel like you needed to know
every single one of them I can't think
of one that you didn't need to know you
did need to know that Alexa SPO is
dating John jinen if you didn't know
that I don't know if you needed to know
that no no Claudia like I don't give a
rip about the OC and when I saw that
like I had to I did a double take this
was a few weeks ago and I went like on a
stalking spree of Alexis Bolino I needed
to know all right before we give
everyone the weekend off let's do a
little bit of Queenie and weenie of the
week so Queenie and weenie of the week
is a new segment here with the toast
that we do every Friday where we're
going to name a weenie of the week
somebody who was just giving weenie
energy this week and a Queenie of the
week someone who was giving Queenie
energy of the week and stated in the
beginning of the show I had a really
hard time coming up with Queenie um so
let me put forth my nominee for weenie
of the week okay my weenie of the week
is
PETA oo that's a good one not only is it
a good one because we spoke about them
at length yesterday doing like losery
ass [__] somebody sent me a screenshot
this morning of PETA doing something
egregious again this week Gypsy Rose
Blanchard posted that she got a dog like
her and her man's like new dog welcome
to the family and Peta like left like a
hate comment what did they say excited
for your new family member next time
adopt don't shop it's like all right
well she already shopped so just leave
her alone yeah and they're just like out
here again in my opinion dying on the
wrong Hills
yeah my weenie of the week oh wait I'm
sorry and a close runnerup for my weenie
of the week was Ryan
Atwood oh that's good I really like
don't have a weenie that's okay you do
Queenie cuz like I don't really have a
que that's good my Queeny of the week
and I feel like we owe a lot of this
week's success in humor to this
man and that's Mickey Mouse wait I never
thought Queenie could be a boy I just
like was always thinking girl yeah you
think girl but also we love to celebrate
women we do love to celebrate women here
at the toast but today we're celebrating
mice because Mickey Mouse really just I
I'm so impressed with him and what he's
built and I feel like this was the week
of realizing that and having an
appreciation for this mouse who works so
hard by the way I absolutely love that
answer and when we were talking at the
beginning of the show about what was
different like it's Mickey that's what I
said like I had the Disney
jiv yep the spirit so I do think Mickey
is a big factor for why these episodes
were fire and he deserves Queenie for
that reason and we made like so many
Clips with about Mickey and like they
all went viral I made so much Mickey
content yep Mickey he was he was great
he is great okay Mickey is the Queenie
of the week and Peta is the weenie of
the week very animal Centric Queenie
weenie segment this week wow and I love
how like even though we're putting down
pea like we're still lifting up animals
that's what we do here like it's not you
know we don't hate animals we love
animals we love them we wish everyone
loved them as much as we do
right so that is our show our fifth and
final and I think we can confidently say
like another Banger in the basket love
you all dearly we're back on Monday in
studio regular stuff make sure to grab
your merch shop toast merch.com we've
got two new kind of sickening very
different sets crew neck and sweatpants
sets you're not going to want to miss
them so check it out again Jackie is in
uh large and I'm in a medium but Jackie
really could have done a medium she
probably should have yeah I probably
should have any day now these will just
be falling off
me thank you guys so much for listening
to the toast of the millennial Morning
Show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give us video
a thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
that's Spotify iTunes Stitcher public
radio iart radio cast box all the places
listen to podcast sign toast leave a
five star VI bet a beautiful setting and
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have a great weekend stay lit stay safe
have a great one love you bye love you
bye